rihanna and asap rocky take their love
to the big apple and now e.t is learning
more about their inseparable bond
[Music]
here's asap and riri going to dinner in
soho over the weekend that's the singer
bringing her fashion a game sporting a
red jockey and eye-catching pair of
heels holding on tight in her man's
furry jacket i'm honestly truly blessed
real you know a source tells e.t the two
who started dating back in 2020 continue
to be inseparable and they didn't hold
back on the pda while shopping in soho
earlier this week
their relationship is in a good place
after a very busy fall with professional
commitments they took some time to relax
and unwind and really connect with each
other i couldn't tell you how happy i am
but the couple's nyc date nights don't
stop there check out asap and riri
having dinner at hot spot pastis looks
like the cold temps didn't bother ree
showing off her legs in a mini skirt
with white laced up heels paired with a
windbreaker and first scarf
and that's asap bundled up opting for
more warm attire
once inside an eyewitness tells e.t the
pair was all snuggled up with the rapper
being extra attentive to the beauty
mogul
quite simply they didn't take their eyes
off each other they are so sweet and
affectionate there were a lot of fans
outside trying to catch a glimpse of
them and he was super protective of her
and made sure she could get through the
crowd safely
[Applause]
[Music]
love on the brain is right last july a
source told e.t riri and asap are madly
in love
[Music]
the source says quote they barely leave
each other's side asap is so grateful
for rihanna she's his biggest
cheerleader and he doesn't take her for
granted and it's true riri is his number
one fan
that's the umbrella singer rapping to
her boyfriend's song peso at a concert
in november
and reese support runs deep it's
something her beau opened up to e.t
about at the premiere of his documentary
stockholm syndrome it was important
having that support in real life you
know and i think it just shows it will
reveal in the doc you know it's just how
it is in real life and asap is all in in
may the rapper called rihanna the love
of his life in an interview with gq she
may never wear it but she save it so our
babies will be flyer than their parents
he told the mat quote relationships are
so much better when you got the one she
amounts to probably like a million of
the other ones as for reese she's a bit
more tight-lipped but her smile says it
all
red carpet official
unh did wonders at the met gal you guys
were a total move that night love to see
you so happy
thank you